rumors are that there was no music why
would you not use the airport Gary music
when I'm turning into Airport Gary oh
that's a good answer yeah well that that
would be the right answer right and I
appreciate that well you tend to like to
[ __ ] well you like to [ __ ] for a
second here and there see rock this is
the greatest moment of the show this is
the only this is the only part I watch
the show for it's your favourite time
everybody as I turn into the greatest
superhero known in entrepreneur land I'm
also the only superhero in
entrepreneurial and for now I'm looking
for my other cast of characters so
please in the comments section tell me
which character you're gonna be that's
gonna complement this universe of
entrepreneurial superheroes but it's
that time again
cue the music d-roc Airport yeah
[Music]
this is this is the co2 yeah pretty cool
right it's similar yep I mean that's the
style I like you know what's you know
what's funny I'm not obsessed with like
I'm I not obsessed with forcing
technology when people aren't using it
if Nike doesn't have people using
technology and their sneakers I surely
am NOT gonna pull that off you know what
I mean
to me I like to react to what's actually
happening versus force something that
I'd like to happen and I think it's a
crucial mistake of most businesses
trying to force their narrative for
their their ambitions down the consumers
throat instead of feeding what the
consumer is telling you they want what's
that I think it comes from audacity and
ego from human behavior of people that
run companies and they think they're
big-time I'm never gonna take the end
consumers attention for granted
New Yorkers window that's my first
windows selfie
that's my first window something but not
my last inspire people today you know
it's funny I don't really care about you
know anything other than getting people
to do right whether it's something I say
whether it's my overall optimism and
energy whether it's an answer to a
question whether it's my relentless
suffocation of excuses or a tactic you
know the reason I think I go very hard
on stage is because I'm trying to find
as many different angle
responds to something different right
it's not just high-energy it's not just
a thoughtful response sometimes it's
even more subtle things like humility
saying the customer's always right
it's not about how it's can I get even
one person to fundamentally take
advantage I mean look what you and I are
doing right now what we're we're live do
you know how much month there used to be
a huge van out there with a satellite
like tippy I don't think people
understand how amazing the opportunity
is so I'm hopeful to inspire or or force
somebody to to try something new right
now thank you thank you so thank you so
much thank you thank you you're welcome
nice meeting you guys Steve you know
just just such a ridiculous life like so
crazy to see entrepreneurship put on
this pedestal we've never never thought
I'd have like screaming girl fans okay
I mean the windows so they and like
these will hurt just like life so weird
good as low get rid of the single best
keynote in the history of this wonderful
country is a
[Applause]
I think that there's a lot of
misconceptions assumptions curiosities
difficulties for a lot of b2b marketers
for a lot of entrepreneurs for a lot of
consumer based companies I think it's a
very binary debate I really think that
we're in a place right now where you
either believe in what I think is
happening or you don't and I think I
want everybody to listen that sentence
very carefully not about what's coming
that's what's about to happen what's
happening versus believing that or not I
think that people don't understand how
much they're gonna regret when they're
older I also think a lot of executives
here are gonna get fired in six years
for being conservative even though
that's what their company's telling them
to do they're gonna be the fall guy and
the fall gal when the company starts
faltering so a bunch of people here are
gonna be out of a job they think they're
being smart and a political animal
and they're gonna get promoted what they
don't realize is that the markets
changing on them and when everybody
looks at them and they were the ones
pushing [ __ ] because the company
wanted them to pull [ __ ] they're
gonna get fired and I don't want that to
happen to them so I'm trying to get them
to die on their sword instead of
somebody else's and I'm trying to focus
on getting them to tell the truth
instead of what they think they need to
do to get another bonus this year thank
you and the reason they're clapping is
they know how true what I just said was
and you're clapping yet conflicted and
I'm empathetic I don't think I'm cool I
don't think you're bad I'm just want to
have these conversations so you can be
thoughtful right like maybe it's time to
have the courage to say what you
actually believe because let me tell you
something
getting killed on somebody else's thesis
sucks you'd rather go down with yours
yeah I'm gonna make it go nice to meet
you I told you since Lisbon last year
Thank You SLA thank you can we take it
just to the shore yeah actually so
what's the question
so my question is what should I use a
raise capital yes sir before you start
maximizing even more margin and just be
patient all right sir
I mean like Wine Library we made no
money the first four years sir so from
23 to 27 there was nothing you know is
like no margin none but enough enough
enough you keep reinvesting you keep
reinvesting you just got to make sure
you're making enough a little bit more a
little bit more a little bit more that's
all so that's what thank you so much
you're welcome for the caviar thank you
great thank you just had a nice chat
with my dad that's always fun Sasha Bo
ease up to some shenanigans yeah I mean
strategies clearly did not what's caught
up I'm working you know when you're an
entrepreneur new and you're a business
you always have some level of anxiety I
think it's talked about it eating [ __ ]
last line defense always on fire I'm
always thrilled when I'm in Europe and I
give a speech and I get off stage for
the last 30 minutes I've looked at every
email and every text and nothing's
really on fire it's like I'm in this
best spirit right now there's a rare
moment very rare moment where nothing's
clear early on fighters from smoke don't
get me wrong there's smoke there's
always smoke but yeah I'm in a funny
zone right now I always liked being on
the other side of things when you're
when you're ahead in your day and in New
York's just getting revved up
it's why I'm always thinking about
London you know because it's already in
action so the update is um I'm super
happy that I only have a bunch of smoke
situations nothing there it's not a
five-alarm inferno
are you sure how are you good good
amazing
it's awesome infinity I was a big dog
before
yes awesome thank you so much thank you
see you yeah let's go well yep
you know what fun fact for a lot of you
that probably don't know this I post my
own [ __ ] I reply as me it's me
yep it's really me and let me let me
actually explain why it's really me
being a practitioner allows me to be the
best strategist allows me to be the best
not like you have to do your own [ __ ]
you know outsource the part that matters
in the part that matters to me is you
that's how I learn that's how I know
it's about listening I'm talking because
I've been doing so much [ __ ]
listening in parallel
always and forever succeeded
you know I keep losing say getting my
loss it's not complaining or anything
like that are you getting this courage
you know I've been through that and I've
just decided just gonna keep going and
go away let's see the box again so dude
why do you think I talk so much about
that yes basically you know everybody
wants to be a number one and if you're
number three or seven so I'll give you a
good piece of advice if you're smart
enough to get there watch and and so you
so you watch Paulette you live here
biggest great here great yeah so you're
in London you're in the UK you look at
the landscape you make a list of 55
number ones that you decide you take a
step back and you watch and you say okay
here's 55 number ones that I like and
then you watch is always watching it's
always listening what do they need
because because the biggest problem
about once you decide you're not a
number one is most people don't know how
to approach a number one
a number one is hard to penetrate a
number one is a number one for a reason
a number one doesn't need a lot of stuff
a number one if you try to sell them the
way sell everybody else you lose before
he started so I always say and I don't
know how much you've heard this I don't
always say but often I say you got a
watch when I have something whether it's
a sneaker or a book d Rock The Rock
asked to make a video for me
five times on email first four times I
didn't even respond
he didn't the amount of people that have
emailed me and said hey you need to make
more video content I normally charge
10,000 I'll do it for you for 2,000
delete delete so he didn't he wanted to
do it for free he had been watching my
content and knew how to make gave me
said some things that made me think he
could you know asked five times got his
chance then delivered and then he built
then stay patient 21 other people and so
the way to hack at number one his first
year to decide which number ones you
like I needed to see what she or he is
into what are their weaknesses or what
are they talking about or how are they
acting then figuring out is that's
something you can bring to the table and
so now you start with 55 you get a read
you're down to 12 like whatever you
think you're good at the fact that
you've already realized you're not a
number ones already means you're willing
to be self-aware and then you attack up
sales
or or you need a team that already has
sales taken care of because a number one
necessarily is in sales you know you
could you could run you could you could
create a partnership 50/50 which
somebody has created sales and you're
great at whatever you think you're ready
or you could go work for an organization
where you can learn but it's don't just
assume a number one needs to be great at
sales some number ones are not rated
sales they're great at management
they're great at structure the great at
branding I would argue I'm not great at
sales I'm so good at branding that it
trickles into sales but I don't love
asking people I'm very uncomfortable
with it I don't love it I can do it I've
done it I'm probably good at it but I
far prefer it come to me then mean cut
right because that's how you really sell
so those are some thoughts
it's all self-awareness brother it's all
supple what like like I could I mean I
understand finances but compared to my
brother my CFO my dad Steven Ross I'm
not as good as them I don't understand
the tax code the angles there's a lot of
things where I lose money but I'm ok
with that because there's a lot of
things I'm great at and it's important
to understand yourself when you're
tricking yourself you get into a bad
place that's why so many people are
upset yeah they want to be something
instead of figuring out who they are
they want to be something that's the
problem they aspire to be something
they've subjectively decided is cool
first I get listen you know how scared I
am that of my brand getting big and
everybody weak it was a question today I
don't want anybody to be me
I'm very unique in my background and
upbringing there can be people that are
me I want them to be like me and the
fact that I'm fully me and then you need
to be fully used yeah the other thing is
too many people think like people don't
understand that money is not the play
like I say it all the time
137,000 is a ton fifty thousand you can
have a very happy life for fifty
thousand especially if you're at peace
in your mind and you love being a
janitor a secretary and admin like
people are getting confused they're
getting confused they want stuff that
doesn't matter
they want stuff that doesn't happen it's
a whirlwind whoa I have no idea how I I
don't know how I did yeah of course you
keep never the best part of this whole
lot log I didn't drop it
good day so far go into an influence
ramita then I'm gonna sleep for two
hours and watch the Jets stun the bills
and then think day tomorrow Copenhagen
Moscow LA four cities in Australia it's
pretty crazy out here and then we got
this weird are freaking us out watch
this
yep you know yeah build the biggest
building in town without tearing down
everybody else's building I think that
that's a very big thing for me
I also started saying things like
winners win you're not gonna stop a
winner I'm just surprised by how much
time and energy people spend on trying
to make somebody they're competing with
like lose by them talking bad behind
their back you know that's how I'm
winning I have a lot of competitors who
spend their entire dinner with the
client talking about me that's when you
win like I'm not worried about anybody
else and so my weirdly hope everybody
I'm like I'm pumped at Chris Sacca make
more money than me
wouldn't be investing at the same time
he deserved it it was more right like I
don't begrudge that I applaud it
if anybody beats me ever and as long as
it's fair well then I think that's the
best it you know it keeps me grounded
hungry and not also genuinely am happy
for somebody else I look there's so much
money and opportunity in the system
nobody's stopping you from getting yours
if you're if you think some guy or some
gals winning and that's coming out of
your pocket you suck if I can create
successful entrepreneurs and they create
successful entrepreneurs like I I think
I'm putting such good into the world I
could you become a platform I think you
can't be a platform in your bad because
you're selfish you're closed by nature
but if I feel like I'm open source
entrepreneurship I'm free when I'm
putting on my best [ __ ] and I'm great
and I'm putting on my best [ __ ] daily
for free
and so in a weird way I think I'm more
similar to open-source like I'm not
keeping my best ideas to myself so I can
keep the money I'm trying to empower I
want people to win Jordan right I wanted
Jordan to be successful now he's
successful fitness personality and that
helps other people you know do that
[Laughter]
[Music]